we've continually improved link ever
since we launched but sometimes change
can't be done incrementally sometimes
you have to clear the slate and start
again to achieve your vision and that is
what we've done with link to point 0
we've revamped major components of the
site to give it a clean fresh look and
to give the user a brand-new experience
learn is where you find lessons and
study them friends is where you interact
with members and tutors teach is where
you manage your tutoring activities and
tasks is where you find shortcuts to the
main activities on the site these four
simple controls are easy for newcomers
to learn and super efficient for power
users and that's just the start the new
learn page is like a control center for
link the timeline is a chronological
list of your learning activities and
site notifications want to find that
lesson you were just studying there it
is time to review that writing
correction or answer that conversation
request it's all right there in your
timeline on the other side of the page
you'll find recommendations these are
the courses or lessons that other
members are sharing as a lesson is
shared it moves to the top of the list
this gives you a constantly refreshing
list of lessons at your level that our
members are recommending as someone who
has learned to speak 12 languages
including five in the last 10 years I've
always felt that what mattered the most
to me was finding interesting material
to learn from that was at my level in
link to point 0 when you browse for
content new lessons open lessons
imported lessons they're all in one
place it's important to note that
courses replaces the old collections and
playlists replaces the old courses we
feel this terminology more accurately
reflects what these things do you can
view new lessons in the library lessons
you have already taken in my lessons or
lessons you have previously imported
select between lessons courses or
playlists depending on what you are
looking for
you can even filter your results further
when you find a lesson you like open it
if you really like it you may want to
add it to a playlist or share it with
others using the drop down menu
playlists are new to link winter
playlist playlist are a customized way
for you to collect lessons together to
suit a particular interest you have for
future study a lesson can belong to more
than one playlist you can even share
these playlists with other members to
help them maybe you're a tutor and want
to direct members learning your language
to some relevant content that you have
created or shared we think that
playlists will help everyone keep track
of good content and share it with others
to me it's about performance the site
has to work as efficiently and smoothly
as possible to allow people to focus on
what's important which is learning the
language ideally the technology the
system fades into the background what we
have done to the lesson page the core
page of our site is revolutionary we
fell in love with this new functionality
while testing and we've been waiting
impatiently for it to launch so we could
use it with our real account data the
new interface is much cleaner while at
the same time providing quicker access
to all functionality everything is
literally at your fingertips the text is
now fixed at an optimal width which
makes it easier to read as before new
words are highlighted in blue and links
the words you are learning in yellow on
the right in the dashboard pain you'll
find a new HTML audio player which works
well on all devices and platforms
including iOS devices you will also find
all information and resources related to
the lesson see the number of new words
and links in the lesson click to see the
new words or link terms drill down on a
term to see more information in the text
you'll notice that the word you're
looking up is bordered in red the
vocation of this word is now stored so
you can easily see where you are in the
lesson and find your way back if you
have to navigate away for some reason
like a bookmark but better but what
really gets us excited is the way you
can now quickly flip through these blue
new words just using your keyboard
the left/right arrow keys move you from
one new word to the next seamlessly and
the lesson text scrolls to keep up use
the up down arrow keys to choose the
best hint or option for the word and
enter to selectively there are also
options for ignore and known or you can
simply type X for ignore and k4 known we
wanted linking to be instant without a
lot of mousing the result is powerful
for vocabulary acquisition reviewing
links in the text is now just as easy as
dealing with your blue words just press
shift and the right or left arrow key to
switch from blue to yellow words now the
left and right arrow keys flip through
your links manage your tags view
examples see all user hints ask a tutor
for help review your notes while you
flip and while the text scrolls with you
all changes are automatically saved
lesson resources like videos
translations scripts and more are also
displayed in the dashboard red
indicators show which resources are
available just click to access a
specific resource from the drop-down
list more streamlined more functional
and fast we think you're going to love
it and if you're on a device with a
smaller resolution you can even minimize
the dashboard and use the full screen
for text highlighted words function as
they did in the original link app more
than two billion people have access to
the Internet to us that means amazing
opportunities to connect with learners
and speakers from all over the globe and
all this from your very own home as we
began this project of redoing link from
the ground up a core part of our vision
was enhancing the way that members
interact at link we knew from the start
that we had to make member interaction
more meaningful and more convenient in
order to create a truly vibrant learning
community the friends section features a
brand new activity wall front and center
now users can share updates links to
other sites videos images and more and
with privacy settings for each post you
can control what to share and more
importantly what to keep private you can
subscribe to specific users updates by
adding them as a friend giving you more
control over what you see in your feed
filter by less than
or conversations to see what your
friends are up to in your target
language of course part of the fun is in
the interaction and that's why we've
also added a comment box below each and
every post that appears allowing you to
comment on what other people have shared
if you like a post you can click the +
rose button to give it a rose if you
really like it you can even click the
share button and share it on your own
feed each time you click + rose on
someone's post a rose will be added to
the Rose total the sharing of lessons is
unique when you share a lesson you're
also giving it a rose this means that it
will be pushed to the top of the
recommendations list on the learn page
link to point 0 is not just an update
it's a genuine reinvention of the link
concept and a significant step forward
for language learners everywhere link is
now more portable more fun and more
effective the rest is up to you